ང་
ང་ཡོད་(བ་)
ང་ས་ལ་སྡོད་ཡ་དགའ་པོ་ཡོད།
ང་རྔན་པ་ཟ་ཡ་ཡིན།
Cheese ཟ་ཡ་ཡིན། ཨ་ནི་ཡོད་(བ་)
སྒོར་སྒོར་རྔན་པ་དེ་ཟ་ཡ་ཡིན།
མོ་ཊ་ཉོ་ཡ་ཡིན།
ཚོན་མདོག་ཟིང་སྐྱ་
ཡག་པོ་འདུག
གྲོགས་མོ་ཟླ་མཛེས། ལོ་ལྔ་རེད།
ཟླ་མཛེས་ར་
ཨ་ནི་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་ཡ་དགའ་པོ་ཡོད་རེད། ༼ཡིག་རེས་གུ་རེས་༽རྩེད་ཡ་དགའ་པོ་ཡོད་རེད།
ཟླ་མཛེས་༼ཡིག་རེས་གུ་རེས་༽དགའ་པོ་དཔེ་ཡོད་རེད།  ༼འོ་༽བྱས་ནས་རེད།
ཟླ་མཛེས་ཨི་འདྲའི་འདྲ་བོ་ཟ་ཡ་དགའ་པོ་ཡོད་རེད།
སྤྲིན་བལ་རྔན་པ་རེད།
ང་ཡང་སྤྲིན་བལ་རྔན་པ་ལ་དགའ་པོ་ཡོད།
སྤྲིན་བལ་རྔན་པ་ལ་མངར་མོ་དཔེ་འདུག
ང་གཟའ་སྤེན་པ་ལ་རེད་(བ)།
གཟའ་ཉི་མ་ལ་རེད་(བ་)ང་ཇག་མ་གོན་གྱི་ཡོད།
གཟའ་སྤེན་པ་ལ་ཇག་མ་གོན་གྱི་ཡོད།
གཟའ་དེ་ཚོ་ལ་
གཉིས་གཉིས་རུ་སྒྲིག་ནས་འགྲོ་དགོས་རེད།
ང་གཟའ་སྤེན་པ་ཉི་མ། གཟའ་ཟླ་བ་ཨི་འདྲའི་འགྲོ་དགོས་རེད།
ག་ལེར་ག་ལེར་ཕལ་འགྲོ་དགོས་རེད། ཚུལ་ཡོང་དགོས་རེད།
ང་ཐུག་པ་ཟ་ཡ་དགའ་པོ་ཡོད། དུག་སྦྲང་ ཐུག་པ་ལེབ་ལེབ་དེ་
འཐེན་ཐུག་ལབ་ན་ག་རེ་ལབ་ཀྱི་ཡོད་རེད། ཨི་་་དུག་སྦྲང་ཆེན་པོ་
རི་བོ་དང་རི་སྦལ་རྒྱུགས་ཤར་གློད་ཡ་༼ཁ་གྱི་༽ ང་བཤད་ཐུབ་ཀྱི་མེད།
TVནང་ལ་ལྟ་ནས་ལབ་ན་ཤེས་གི་རེད་
TVནང་ལ་སྡོན་འདྲེ་བསྟན་མོ་སྟོན་གྱི་འདུག
སྡོན་འདྲེ་དེ་ར་ནང་ལ་བསྡད་གྱོག་དེ་སྟོན་གྱི་འདུག
ནང་ལ་བསྡད་ཨི་འདྲའི་བྱེད་ཀྱི་འདུག
སྡོན་འདྲེ་དེ་མི་འདུག་གས་ འོ་དེ་མི་གཅིག་འདུག་(ད་)(ར་)སྡོན་འདྲེ་གྱི་ནང་ལ་ར་
མི་དེ་ཤི་ཚར་འདུག་(ད་)(ར་)ཡང་བསྐྱར་ཟ་ག་འགྲོ་གི་འདུག
ཡང་བསྐྱར་མི་གཅིག་རོགས་པ་དེ་ཁོ་བསླེབ་དུས་ར་ཨ་ནི་ར་མི་དེ་
རྐང་པ་འཐེན་ནས་འགྲོ་སོང་། རྫོགས་སོང་།